c'est très c'est très émouvant pour moi
d'être sur la scène de ce théâtre
évidemment le théâtre de champ fleuri
parce que j'y suis allé très souvent
quand j'étais petit parce que j'étais à
samedi parce que je suis dionysien et
puis le le théâtre de saint-gilles parce
que j'ai vu certains des plus beaux
concerts de ma vie je sais pas si tu
voir golman tu vois
j'ai les jambes l'auberge et vu des
comics bedos j'ai vu enfin j'en ai j'en
ai vu plein plein plein et et j'ai vu
des créoles
j'ai vu jardinot
donc bah ouais mais d'être là ça me fait
ça me remplit de joie et d'émotion c'est
juste qu'il faut que je travaille plus
quand je suis sur scène je veux bien
être assis regarder un autre gars
travailler